[Música]
mitigar a fome é abrandar a miséria é
erradicar a pobreza é mudar o mundo
a gente colocou esse título com a idéia
de de tentar mostrar que as ações que
vêm sendo desenvolvidas hoje em
políticas públicas globais estão mais
voltadas para essa história do
assistencialismo
então nós temos muito dinheiro envolvido
muita gente trabalhando em tentar
mitigar a fome como se a fome não
tivesse uma causa que é a pobreza no meu
entender pelo menos mais de 700 milhões
de pessoas em situação de pobreza e fome
crônica vivem no mundo segundo dados da
organização das nações unidas por 1,5
bilhão né dessas pessoas com privações
de padrões básicos de saúde e educação
mais de 2,7 milhões de pessoas tentam
sobreviver com menos de dois dólares por
dia
a primeira urgência da pobreza é
realmente a fome e esse slide não
precisa de legenda
basta olhar a expressão dos olhos ea
expressão das mãos dessas pessoas diante
de um pedaço de pão e um prato pequeno
prato de comida
segundo os médicos sem fronteira 7
milhões 7 mil crianças morrem por dia em
decorrência da fome 7 mil crianças
morrem por dia
desidratação
a subnutrição a pobreza é realmente
opressiva bilhões de dólares segundo
também a onu são investidos por ano em
ajuda humanitária no mundo
é um número enorme de um valor enorme de
recursos jogando dinheiro na áfrica em
regiões da américa central da américa é
do sul e é com relação à a combater a
fome na américa do sul cerca de 90
milhões de pessoas são beneficiadas por
esses programas assistencialistas
o investimento anual equivalente a 4% do
pib da região
segundo o portal brasil o governo
brasileiro destinou mas mais 2,5 bilhões
ao bolsa família só em outubro deste ano
quase 14 milhões de famílias estão
inscritos no bolsa família
o objetivo seria ofertar uma renda per
capta igual ou superior a 85 reais
mensais
mas essa parte debaixo desse slide
este valor é o valor de corte que define
o que é linha de pobreza extrema
então tá claro pra gente muito claro que
existe número sendo manipulados nessa
história
ou seja a partir dessa linha de cortes
quem ganha 85 reais per capta por mês
não tem pobreza extrema e então o
governo tá tirando da pobreza extrema 14
milhões de famílias o que não é real
ninguém vive com 85 é reais por dia
então essa análise desse dado uma
análise muito simples né demonstra que
no slide anterior gente viu que tinha um
número enorme de pessoas tentando
sobreviver com dois dólares ao dia o que
daria três vezes quase esse valor que é
o valor de corte do bolsa família onde
estabelece
que a partir daí você não é não tem mais
pobreza extrema
então isso é real pra mim quanto maior o
número de famílias no bolsa família mais
o país está desgraçado mais o país está
miserável porque nós estamos atendendo
com essa renda per capta pessoas que não
têm possibilidade de sobrevivência
o banco mundial enfim reconhece que os
2,6 bilhões de dólares bilhões de
dólares gastos em projetos extrativistas
não ajudaram as populações locais locais
a saírem da pobreza
esses investimentos feitos em
estrativistas em áreas de floresta ou
com pescadores ensinando o pescador a
pescar o peixe que vai comer ou a catar
coquinho para vender na praia é não tem
dado resultado do ponto de vista
econômico para deslocar essa pobreza
crônica pra um tipo de economia ou de
ingressos que seja capaz de as pessoas
viverem por si só
qual é o nosso desafio diante disso e
diante dessa realidade que a gente
começa a ver políticas públicas sendo
repetidas há vários anos a vários
governos a várias ideologias e de uma
forma global
nós temos que pensar em outra coisa
vamos começar a pensar em projetos
estruturantes e como ong como ng o
instituto ecoengenho do qual eu faço
parte que estamos analisando esse
processo e fazendo alguns projetos que
nós vamos mostrar aqui nós imaginamos
esse desafio produzir com pobres para
vender para ricos identificar produtos
de alto valor agregado nichos especiais
de mercado para comercialização
introduzir inovações tecnológicas
utilizando energia renovável práticas
sustentáveis ambientalmente corretas
difundir esta nova ética dos micro
sistemas produtivos e relacionamento
entre classes com ênfase na reflexão
social
dentro desse contexto nós descobrimos
alguns anos atrás e já aplicamos
inclusive esse slide mas eu volto com
ele um slide de sítio
achas uma comunidade perdida no meio da
região semi árida de alagoas é em são
josé da tapera onde as pessoas vivem um
tipo de artesanato de palha de ouricuri
dona josefa com suas duas filhas
carregando o pai o tempo todo enquanto
as irmãs enquanto as outras parentes e
as outras mulheres estão carregando água
essa é a realidade deles no sertão a
copa é hora que você chegue lá e aí nós
tivemos a ousadia de instalar um sistema
hidropônico e quase fomos execrados por
isso porque os grupos ideológicos não
permitiriam que isso é uma mudança de
cultura local
ora não tem água não tem energia não tem
nada como eu posso produzir uma
comunidade 10 através de um sistema
fotovoltaico de geração de energia
elétrica a partir do sol
eu morro uma pequena bomba que custa 300
400 reais pego essa água com nutrientes
jogos com a caixa d'água superior e
distribuo nesses canteiros feitos com
garrafa pet itaqui o tejo na primeira
garrafa que saiba a segunda a terceira
ea quarta para quinta que é recolhido e
volta pra caixa d'água inferior fechando
um circuito está aqui dentro é usado
carvão de casca de arroz simplesmente
para assegurar a raiz da planta e nesse
momento todo mundo dizia mas vamos
plantar o quê e em couro parece que a
história vinha uma horta comunitária não
a comunidade vai comer a horta
comunidade tem fome e isso não vai gerar
renda
nós precisamos para inovar nesse
processo também a idéia do projeto ea
idéia dos patrocinadores nós eram
realmente gerar renda e não simplesmente
é fazer um projeto de segurança
alimentar não era papel de onde fazer
isso nesse momento e aí o projeto deu
certo a implantação os pimenta como
produto de alto valor agregado às
pimentas cresceram nas suas garrafinhas
tá aí uma grande produção maravilhosa né
e aí pegamos esse pessoal e treinamos
capacitamos dentro de técnicas
bem aprender fazendo porque eles não
sabem ler eles têm baixíssima
escolaridade e chegamos a ficar á a
estabilizar o produto no local
ou seja a partir daí nós saímos não com
a pimenta para vender com baixíssimo
valor agregado mas saímos daqui com um
produto beneficiado dentro de regras de
e técnicas de higiene e qualidade até o
produto ser rotulado embalados e chegar
então com essa qualidade ao mercado
então tá aí um produto bonito dá vontade
de comer mesmo quem não gosta de pimenta
ea gente fez até adendo pouco que é pra
quem não gosta começar a gostar
até porque ela tem alguns princípios
básicos que são medicinais né e à então
entra a última parte do projeto daqueles
daquelas regrinhas que a gente começou a
estabelecer para nós mesmo que é o nicho
especial de mercado então chegamos aqui
com os hotéis
komba restaurantes com supermercados com
gormie terias vendendo esse produto uma
parceria com os empresários
e aí a comunidade que a gente encontrou
naquela época que pra mim essa foto é
uma foto icônica porque é uma foto de
graciliano ramos na quem leu vidas secas
sabe que inclusive a cachorrinha baleia
que não é baleia nesse caso é piaba
evidentemente que não estava à altura de
graciliano para ter uma baleia e então
fizemos uma piaba e essa população hoje
essas pessoas é essa mulher vivem nesse
outro ambiente e só quem não está por
como no conto de graciliano ramos foi a
piaba que morreu tanto com a baleia
então essa foi uma história do primeiro
projeto nós mas o mundo como nós
conhecemos foi construído com ervas
aromáticas e especiarias e então
descobrimos aqui né a pimenta rosa no
litoral sul do estado de alagoas nós
descobrimos a aroeira que é uma árvore
nossa da mata atlântica cujo fruto é a
pimenta rosa que é tem uma 1
bom ou utilização em larga escala na
culinária mundial inclusive com maior
utilização na frança chamada de baby 11
o nome é bem mais bonito do que pimenta
e essa árvore e aí não estão aí os
pratos né o uso cumê da pimenta rosa no
mundo todos nós temos folhetos nós de
pratos foram feitos por cloreto agoco
felipe bronze e tal que adoram usar esse
tipo de produto e aqui o vanderson do
picuí tantos outros que também já
venceram a rixa paria que hoje já usa
fábricas de chocolate na bahia então é
isso aí foi realmente um sucesso chegar
à a idéia desse projeto também no campo
dos óleos essenciais né esses olhos são
usados uma grande demanda de de perfumes
franceses de cremes a própria natura e
outras empresas que mexem com os médicos
estão usando isso com com grande escala
descobrimos então nessa comunidade de
piaçabuçú no litoral sul famílias que
faziam a coleta disso dessa dessa
aroeira e levavam para beneficiamento em
suas casas
veja aqui como era feito o
beneficiamento com o pai as crianças
fazendo e e
o resultado disso era todo encaminhado
para o sul do país vendido a um preço de
r$1 e 50 o quilo era esse o ganho que
tinha por um quilo de aroeira nessa
região da pimenta rosa
criamos então o projeto aroeira
arranjamos patrocinadores fizemos o
treinamento dessas pessoas nos
mobilizamos a comunidade passamos um ano
nessa discussão
aí fizemos treinamento da coleta para
que tenhamos coletas mais seletivas
essas pessoas capacitadas passaram a ir
para o campo com seus crachás mostrando
que foram treinadas que adquirir um
conhecimento não só o fato de ganhar
dinheiro foi importante mas ganhar
informação ganhar conhecimento isso
ninguém rouba os ladrões podem até levar
o dinheiro que elas ganham mas não vão
levar
mas o conhecimento que elas obtiveram
neste tipo de trabalho e aí montamos uma
estrutura né que é um pequeno galpão não
é tão grande assim bem simples mas
colocamos um coletor solar para gerar
quente isso o projeto nosso também
aqui nós geramos a quente só há uma rede
de canos aqui dentro e fizemos um painel
também fotovoltaico gerando energia
elétrica e injetando na rede através do
inversor que permite essa injeção na
rede elétrica gerando economia de
energia não é nenhuma substituição mas
um processo de energia para que eu tenho
uma produção a custo mais baixo e que
tenha competitividade no mercado deste
produto e aí montamos a linha de
produção daí as mulheres tratando a
pimenta com equipamentos certos com
ferramentas corretas
os fornos termossolares também
construídos com pessoas de lá com os
serralheiros de lá é com pessoal que
mexe constrói box de banheiro e tal nós
levamos e fizemos essa construção é
muito simples takk a parte interna
simples mas tecnicamente correto você vê
que é tudo de alumínio tela de aço inox
e tal ou seja não há contaminação do
produto de limpeza fácil né
e aí as mesas de seleção então aqui nós
fizemos essas mesas onde aroeira ou de
pimenta rosa é selecionada grão a grão e
todo mundo se espantou mas vai ser um
absurdo é muito o trabalho e tal é mas a
gente não tinha idéia de que essa
produção nós fôssemos o maior produtor
de aroeira do brasil o maior produtor de
pimenta rosa mas que iriam certamente te
a melhor
pimenta rosa do brasil e hoje nós temos
esse feedback a os chefs de cozinha do
rio de janeiro são paulo a ama como
fábrica de chocolate na bahia tem
comprado a aroeira da associação aroeira
quando eu digo nossa foi pela nossa
participação do projeto mas é deles e
thaís sendo produzida
itaqui dona neide é dona neide fazendo a
parte
afinal a seleção depois que a aroeira
vem para um uma medição de umidade
relativa para que possa ser vazada com
pelo menos cinco por cento no máximo 5%
de umidade
então aroeira se transforma num tubinho
de 30 gramas que nós vamos mostrar daqui
a pouco e com o domínio dessa cadeia
produtiva
nós saímos de um real e 50 para até 160
reais pelo mesmo quilo de sal pimenta
como produto lícito
eu não conheço nenhum que tenha uma
agregação de valor nesse nível até então
e é possível e isso não é uma idéia não
é uma teoria está sendo vendido está
sendo vendido a 100 reais o quilo a 120
e 130 160 a mais do que isso líquido as
pessoas estão votando no bolso hoje esse
dinheiro líquido em vez de um real e 50
a pimenta rosa então surge como uma
especiaria brasileira na receita da
inclusão social sustentável
todos lucram produtores consumidores e
empresários comunidade governo
trata-se de riqueza gerando riqueza né
com ética e eficiência e os lucros
advindos deste processo englobam todos
os tipos de capital financeiro social e
tecnológico e científico todos
mensuráveis
já passou do tempo de convidar o mundo
para esta transformação inadiável
precisamos estabelecer relacionamentos
éticos viver e conviver valorizando a
interconexão inevitável entre todos os
seres sistemas e dinâmicas do planeta
enfim mitigar a fome é realmente
necessário
mas é preciso viver além de sobreviver
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]